it's in places like West Bromwich that
Tory fortunes could turn would you vote
for Liz Tross yes or no no would I vote
for Liz truss
no would you vote for Liz Tross yes or
no no don't know much about it but from
what I've heard no no
no
chance like so many red wool seats
there's a slim blue majority here and
the new prime minister isn't Landing
well I don't like the wreath and things
she's done with you know deducting the
tax for the the uh the IR bracket
um I don't think that was the way to go
actually
as Liz truss meeting the Danish Prime
Minister this morning tries to shake off
claims she's trashing the UK economy
devolved Finance ministers in Scotland
Wells and Northern Ireland have written
to the chancellor warning of a new age
of austerity we are really concerned
that there was absolutely nothing
whatsoever in the mini budget to
recognize the pressures on public
services in Wales we know that our
budget is worth the billion pounds less
over this three-year spending period
because of the impact of inflation
inevitably that's going to have an
impact on public services and we share
these concerns across the devolved
governments and awaiting Liz trust at
the Party Conference in Birmingham Tory
MPS most of whom didn't vote for her
many feel Vindicated even allies
privately admit she's failed to sell her
vision well Tory MPS I speak to are most
worried about is the party's reputation
with the economy and the signs are that
to square that Circle the government
could go in the direction of big
spending cuts potentially welfare Cuts
politically that is going to be very
hard to sell we are giving the signals
to the markets and to others that we
intend to be extremely of us when it
comes to bearing down on a public
expenditure now that that will be
developed in the weeks ahead we've got a
whole range of announcements coming out
on not just uh spending but also on
supply side reforms Liz truss has never
had a problem Charming the party
faithful but this week it won't just be
her allies watching it'll be the markets
the voters the unhappy MPS that didn't
even show
[Music]
she'll need to pitch beyond the
conference Hall if she's to restore
faith in the party
[Applause]